we have the first casualty from Sacha
Baron Cohen's new show who is America
Baron Cohen is of course the actor who
has developed such characters as Ali G
Borat Bruno and in this new show that he
has on Showtime he plays a a new
character he's an Israeli firearms
instructor named Iran Murad who claims
to support everything from burka bands
to training four-year-olds to use
firearms and he has gotten some really
high-profile interviews pat including
everybody from I don't even know where a
standard Sanders hiyo Sarah Palin I
think realized that something wasn't
right or she bailed Roy Moore was
interviewed by him and today we have the
first casualty which is Jason Spencer
Jason Spencer's a Georgia state lawmaker
he was apparently so taken with Colonel
Iran Murad that he ended up supporting a
burqa ban yelling the n-word incessantly
pretending to be an Asian tourists
during which he adopted a stereotypical
Asian accent and at one point actually
dropped his pants to quote use his
buttocks to intimidate Isis here is a
piece of the video n-word warning but I
think that his buttocks is going to be
blurred out for people that are watching
take a look at this because of who you
are you could be the victim of
kidnapping by Isis you have two seconds
to attract attention how do you attract
attention
you start screaming take your clothes
off in America there is one forbidden
world it is the N world now I am going
to be the terrorist you have three
seconds to attack the tension go you
crazy the N word is nuni not this world
this world is disgusting
Isis of scared of being seen as Omo you
know it it mean Omo if your buttock
touch them it means they have become a
homosexual now I am going to teach you
how to use your buttocks to intimidate
Isis show me the buttock no trousers
down
okay go America good one more time but
louder with America we say in the Mossad
I mean not in the Mossad if you want to
win you show some skin ok
ok show it to me now
try to touch me I'll touch you touch you
with my bags
I'll touch you you will drop the gun
he'll touch you you are say ok stop you
have to remind me if I touch you you
will become a homosexual
ok now try to touch me go go go go ok
yes on you show me your weapon go touch
it homosexual you drop that gun right
now you act think the most incredible
thing is that when you watch this clip
Spencer's behavior is so insane and so
outrageous that it's actually hard to
believe he's not an actor and that this
is all scripted it's so wack that it
seems like Spencer is working for the
show but he wasn't and he's now
resigning after this he is blaming Sasha
Baron Cohen saying that he was taking
advantage of he put out a statement
through the Atlanta journal-constitution
saying that quote imposing is an Israeli
agent Cohen pretended to offer
self-defense exercises as uncomfortable
as I was to participate I agreed to
understanding that these quote
techniques were meant to help me and
others fend off what I believed was an
inevitable attack I deeply regret the
language I used at Cohen's request as
well as my participation in the class
in general if I had not been so
distracted by my fears I never would
have agreed to participate in the first
place
obviously the first thing anybody does
when they believe that their family may
be at risk is you go somewhere and you
start yelling the N word out incessantly
like you're having a grand old party and
he's framed himself as just being so
scared that he was scared into
participating because of fear for his
family imagine just for a second okay
here's what I was thinking about Pat if
you can get Jason Spencer to say on
camera the N word like it's a party and
fake an Asian accent what is he willing
to do behind the scenes and what could a
lobbyist get him to do by offering him
some money yeah I mean he was totally
exposed here right I don't think I I
think he does genuinely believe these
things deep down and would say these
things in private
I agree normally you wouldn't do that on
camera but he was duped here and I think
that's the genius of Sasha Baron Cohen
we you're better off that Jason Spencer
is resigning now a lot of people do have
a problem with what Sasha Baron Cohen is
doing they're saying you you are
misrepresenting the person that you are
and thus the entire thing is sort of
dishonest at its base I don't know that
that's a good that could be an argument
against Sacha Baron Cohen's a format
right that how he does what he does with
Ali G Borat whoever but that's not a
defense of Jason Spencer because I don't
care what costume Sacha Baron Cohen puts
on I'm not gonna start yelling the N
word out incessantly right it's just not
gonna happen I don't care what costume
or who he claims to be yeah I mean your
true colors are revealed here and some
people are failing the test others are
passing the test that's Cortney Sanders
for example he wasn't fooled by it he
could kind of pick up on the fact that
Sasha was playing her character and even
Sarah Palin and she as we're told Sarah
Palin identified that the person
claiming to be a so-called veteran of
the service was actually Sacha Baron
Cohen and was not a former service
member and walked out of the interview
not everybody is falling for this stuff
and we are all better off with Jason
Spencer resigning I think that there is
no question about that if you disagree
that Spencer should have to resign as a
result of this please let me know and
you can discuss it on the david pakman
show subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di T today's program brought to you
in part by Blink accom / pakman blinka
is a great service that i use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listen to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa que mas